now is a terrible horrible no good very
bad time to buy a car sure inflation is
slowing down and Supply chains are
coming back online but now might be the
worst time ever to buy a car especially
a new car there are three big reasons
that Americans who go car shopping right
now are going to pay more and get less
for their money high prices high demand
poor selection I'll explain first let's
talk about those high costs new car pric
are Skyhigh right now 5 years ago there
were a dozen new car models that sold
for less than $20,000 in 2023 there's
one the Mitsubishi Mirage hatchback woo
swagon it's true that new car prices
have been coming down since hitting
record highs but US Treasury yields
recently Rose their highest level in
more than 15 years we've seen a similar
increase in the rates for auto loans and
the cost of financing a car hit an
all-time high in the SE second quarter
so drivers who finance their vehicle are
actually paying more than when prices
were higher car shopping website Edmonds
found that a record 177% of customers
who financed were paying more than
$1,000 a month and then there's
insurance and maintenance the latest CPI
inflation report showed Motor Vehicle
Insurance costs Rose by 19% from a year
ago that was the largest increase of all
items in the report and just below auto
insurance was the 12% increase in
maintenance cost for cars and
trucks Oh and the United Auto Workers
recently announced a strike at the big
three automakers so car production could
slow even further the UAW is Seeking a
46% pay increase over 4 years so this
fight could last a while and once it's
done car prices might just go up again
car prices are being held up by high
demand which means there's a lot of
people trying to buy production slowed
down significantly in recent years and
that is has left a shortage of millions
of new cars people didn't just stop
needing new cars because they weren't
being produced so folks who couldn't buy
then are trying to buy now that's
creating something of a Feeding Frenzy
on Lots the latest inventory report from
Cox Automotive found that while
inventory has rebounded from 2021 and
2022 levels it has remained Low by
historical standards and we all know
what happens when there's high demand
and low Supply it's hard for price has
to come down very much that lack of
production in recent Years also means
that used cars are fewer and older than
in years past 51% of used cars sold in
the second quarter were more than 3
years old that's up from 42% before the
pandemic according to Edmonds so what's
it all mean it could mean that now is a
good time to invest in a nice bicycle or
a bus pass the latest CPI report shows
new vehicle prices have fallen in three
of the last five months and used car and
truck prices have fallen by more than
62% from last year so you might want to
wait or lower your standards a bit
whatever you do now is definitely not a
good time to buy a new
car